hi CNN it's me Gilmore here with my
panel from today's show actor director
and author of The forthcoming book easy
money Ben McKenzie is over here
democratic congresswoman from California
Katie Porter
and host to talk to these Piers Morgan
uncentered Piers Morgan here are the uh
here are the questions from people
wanting to know what we think here on
the panel what does the panel make of
the two
Tennessee lawmakers who were expelled
from the state legislature that was a
big story this week we didn't get to it
yes uh they now they were protesting
because there was a shooting there they
wanted you know I think I agree with
what they were saying is we need better
gun control laws but these are
legislators and they used a bull horn
inside The Well of the con the Senate of
Tennessee was it this is state state
legislature yeah
um and interrupted the proceedings which
of course when that happened on January
the 6th in a much larger a more violent
way all the people currently cheering on
the two Tennessee legislators were the
ones who would have been condemning and
castigating what happened
no
here's what I'm comparing when you have
a mob of protesters and they're going
into a legislative chamber whether it's
at the capitol or whether it's in
Tennessee the principle is the same and
if you don't have the same principal
response to both of those things
regardless of scale then you're not
principle though the principle is
different they were Tennessee
legislature legislators who went into
the chamber and admittedly broke the
rules of decorum partly because they
were being silenced when they wanted to
talk following the rules of decorum
about gun violence prevention what
happened on January 6th was a bunch of
batshit crazy with guns who
killed police people here's that is not
the same publicity get it I I like Bill
I agree with what the legislators who
were doing the protesting I agree with
them about guns everyone knows I think
that's why let's see an end it's nice to
be back by the way on CNN um I agree
with them
thank you that's right it's been a while
the last time I was on CNN I was talking
about guns thank you Bill that would
probably get me fired all over again
um but I I just think you in the end
you've got to be consistent about the
way you view but that is that is a
terrible analogy well they're not the
same thing but the principles
a mob of people going in to stop
Democratic procedures but it is not
democracy whether you're on the right or
left okay what what I principle is I
don't think a mob of protest yes I go
into a legislative buildings stop the
proceedings
they were a mob the two guys were a mob
no no all the other people no but here's
the thing these guys are legislators
what I would say to them is look I
admire your passion I'm a liar that
young people your age are in government
I think that's good that you want to be
in government and that just oblivious to
it
um and the issue okay oh we have a valid
point but you're in the legislator now
the legislature you don't need the
bullhorn that's for when you're out on
the street well you have to modulate
this is what this is what they do on
college campuses we just stop you from
talking if we disagree with a bullhorner
shouting they have to leave that behind
now you're inside you're in the building
you got elected the way to affect
changes you write a law do it that way
but the bullhorn was well or outside I
think you have a point I
I think you have a point about they were
in there they had other opportunities
they can introduce the law I also do
want to say that rules of decorum are
often used to silence people who do not
have voices and in this case we're
talking about two younger men two black
men two people in my political minority
in Tennessee and so we've seen rules of
decorum be used over and over and over
again in this country as an excuse to
exclude people and to silence people so
okay I think you're right though that
that that that I can't believe I'm
saying this like I so deeply deeply
agree with you about the January 6th and
how wrong
appears is to try to equivalent I mean I
didn't know so what you were doing was
playing politics I talked purely about a
principle of a mob of people going to
stop Democratic proceedings let's start
happening whether it's on the left or
the right let's start digging
it's been re-elected immediately and
raised all this money in their national
heroes oops
what do you make of Prince Harry's plan
to attend his father's coronation
without Margaret Meghan Markle God why
do we give I don't damn
[Applause]
not me uh
how about that uh what do you make of
Prince Harry's well I don't know why we
care so much uh you could you happen you
couldn't Care America
I hate to say this but America has sent
two women into our royal family the
first was Wallace Simpson who led to an
abdication right number six and the
second is Meghan Markle you are two for
two and it's not looking great so
frankly if you're women here
that's hysterical so what happened so
Prince Harry's going and she's not he's
going and all his family basically want
to kill him and she's staying here
because they feel the same way about her
I mean look from my point of view
they're just a pair of little uh Royal
Renegade grifters who want to have their
wool cake and eat it they want to keep
the titles make hundreds and millions
trashing their family again and again
and again and again and eventually the
Royal Family's gone you know what shut
up
basically with you
I mean I would I would defend Harry it's
only insofar as it he went to
Afghanistan yeah you know I mean he
could have got out of that as certainly
the people in this country do with that
kind of standing and he didn't he went
he did he did honorable service for his
country and he was a beloved Prince to
give you some idea how far he's fallen
he is now less popular than prince
Andrew
right exactly but her thing about you
know the the royal family being racist
maybe they are certainly the history she
never produced a shred of evidence to
support that they were cold to me
they're called to everybody they were
called to Diana and who was whiter than
Diana
they're just cold people
are pretty racist like she did an Oprah
Winfrey you've got to back it up with
some evidence not a shred of evidence
has either of them ever produced for any
racism from the royal family so put up
or shut up and stop smearing our royal
family okay in my opinion then this is
for you how much do you think the
failure to regulate crypto is due to
lawmakers not understanding it well we
just said we don't understand yeah
exactly I mean yeah John tester
no one knows what it is that's right no
sorry sorry we're on CNN
everyone stop swearing on CNN
yeah I gotta get them racing
I do think I do think it's part that
they did that that legislators didn't
understand it but I went there over the
summer I went to DC with with the
journal uh Jacob who's right wrote the
book with me and we had meetings some of
which I talk about in the books and
which I can't talk about and
the general attitude was you're probably
right but I'm sorry Sam Beckman freed
has given us too much money
Sam bankman freed gave yes the Democrats
40 million dollars yeah his Lieutenant
gave the Republicans 23 I believe the
total is somewhere around 90 million
dollars in this straw donor scheme that
is alleged to have happened they bottom
up both off and they bought him off not
necessarily in the sense that they
passed bad legislation which they could
have done there was a bill called Sam's
bill that was going you know through the
AG committee potentially but they kept
them from doing anything that was
actually
would have stopped this Ponzi scheme
from collapsing and ruining tens of
thousands of people's lives if not I
mean millions of people now don't have
access to their Accounts at FDX you've
been very tough on the pitch men
the celebrities are the celebrities are
not the core problem of course they're
just the megaphone necessary to spread
the pawns I think they shouldn't have
done that well of course they shouldn't
have done it I mean they shouldn't I
mean you shouldn't sell unregistered
unlicensed Securities this is a this is
actually against the law
um and you also shouldn't Hawk for the
exchanges that are that are doing that
but they're they're the
this is what happens at the end at the
end of the Ponzi life cycle it gets as
big as possible and you need the biggest
celebrities out there
I don't want name names right but
Lindsay Lohan obviously sorry it's just
but but other other big celebrities to
sell for you and that's what happened
how much of this do you think though was
an enforcement problem versus I mean
because you you just said they are
securities these are you're selling
unlicensed Securities we have a
Securities and Exchange Commission Ponzi
schemes have been illegal for about a
hundred years give or take what's the
explanation that you have for why the
SEC didn't take action uh well a couple
reasons I think one of them is that it's
Regulators don't have much incentive to
pop a bubble and potentially get blamed
for it until it's popped once it's
popped you come in you clean it up you
go oh yeah you shouldn't have done that
but the other the other thing is that
we're the only country in the world that
I'm aware of that separates its
Securities regulation from its
Commodities regulation we have a cftc
and an SEC it's created a gray area we
need someone to oversee these agencies
in my opinion someone to basically
because they're fighting over it and
they're fighting over it why why do I in
part in terms of my opinion the cfdc in
order to get the donations Sam bankman
freed met with the cftc chair 10 times
10 times same about with them well
Monday is tax day and I'm going to be
investing in crypto because
all right thank you CNN we'll see you
next week